So I hope you enjoyed the lectures from
Daniel. Now I'm back for the next few
lectures. I'll be your instructor. So
let me first recap where we are and then
I'm going to introduce the topic for
today. And to do so let's go back to our
usual road map for this class.
So, so far what we have been
investigating is the left hand side
branch of this complicated road map.
That is we have been looking at the
methods that solve the optimal control
problem in open loop form. That is what
we are trying to compute is a sequence
of controls parameterized by time that
optimize a given cost function given in
additive form. And we'll be looking at
two broad classes of methods referred to
as indirect methods and the direct
methods. These two classes of methods
are really complimentary. So in the case
of indirect methods the idea is to first
derive necessary conditions for
optimality. Basically the generalization
of the gradient equal to zero condition
from nonlinear optimization to the
setting of infinite dimensional
optimization namely optimal control. You
saw that uh that necessary optimality
condition boils down to solving a
twopoint boundary value problem that is
or a differential equation with split
boundary conditions.
And historically that's the uh first
methods that has been developed to solve
this class of problems. And then you
also saw the other approach referred to
as direct methods where the idea is to
take the given continuous time optimal
control problem, discretetize it and
once you have discretized the problem
now you're back to the setting of a
nonlinear optimization and then use a
nonlinear solver of your choice in order
to solve that nonlinear optimization
problem.
These days, particularly for robotics,
direct methods uh are more popular
thanks to advances in algorithms. For
example, for nonlinear optimization,
advances in hardware, now feasible to
solve these nonlinear optimization
problems on the edge. something that was
not of course uh feasible both
theoretically and practically say back
in the 60s or 70s when indirect methods
were uh originally conceived. Let's say
indirect methods still have some
usefulness in the field. Sometimes they
can give you a close form solution which
of course is the count. If you have the
explicit uh representation of the
optimal control sequence that's great
because it takes zero time for
implementation and other times even
though we're not going to uh look at
this topic uh more deeply there are some
synergies between the indirect optimal
control and the right optimal control.
So the two methodologies can be
hybridized.
But rather than going more deeply on
this topic today, we're going to switch
to the right branch of this road map.
Namely, we're going to look at the
methods that fall under the class of
closed loop optimal control
methodologies. We're solving the same
problem. The problem doesn't change.
What we ch what changes is the uh
mathematical objects we are optimizing
over that is now our goal is to find an
optimal closed loop control policy.
We are no longer satisfied with finding
an openloop control sequence.
Now we want to find a control law that
maps for all possible states that one
can achieve at time t.
It gives us for all possible states that
one can achieve at time t. the optimal
control U star.
Again, as I said during the first
lecture, the notion of open loop and
closed loop is uh quite natural, but
sometimes may lead to some confusions.
Of course, the behavior of an closed
loop optimal control policy is identical
to the one of an openloop control
sequence. In case the system follows the
nominal trajectory that is the one
induced by the open loop control
sequence.
So you might say why should we bother
about computing a closed loop control
policy. Well something that is not
accounted for in our formulation at
least in our basic formulation is the
presence of disturbances or model
mismatches. So even though
mathematically the problem that we are
solving does involve any disturbances or
model mismatches in practice of course
when you deploy these control laws or
optimal control sequences you're
controlling a system whose underlying
dynamical model is different from the
one that you have used for control
design. An optimal control policy, close
control policy is a more robust object
because the moment that you go off the
nominal trajectory, you know what to do.
While in this case, you will blindly
apply the control that was premputed for
time stamp t no matter what.
Is this part clear? Sometimes it might
lead to some confusions.
>> Yes.
You start X
>> X the same
it maps the state wherever you are in
the world. So you can think of UT as the
right thing to do if you are exactly
along the nominal state trajectory. But
the moment that you move farther from
it, you don't have any guarantee anymore
that it might be the option thing to do
now to develop. Now the question is
okay. So it seems true that closed loop
control policies are more robust and
better in general than open loop control
sequences. How do we solve for them? So
what we're going to do next is to
discuss an algorithm referred to as
dynamic programming that is a very
procedural way to solve for
optimal closed loop control policies.
Then you may say why don't you always
use dynamic programming? Well because
dynamic programming is computationally
much more intensive.
So the one hand you have something that
is more powerful closed loop control
policies but much more computationally
intensive. On the other hand you have
something that is computationally much
more feasible but less powerful.
That will lead us to MPC model control
where we try to get the best of both
worlds. We try to reason in terms of a
clo closed loop control policies but in
some sense with the same computational
footprint of openloop control
methodologies. That's what we will see
in a couple of weeks. So does the plan
make sense for the next two three weeks.
All right.
So then the task is uh how do we find an
algorithm that allows us to solve for an
optimal closed loop control policy?
To do that we're going to derive the
algorithm first in a discrete time
setting. Next week we will extend the
derivation to the continuous time
setting.
So for the discrete time setting what we
have is essentially the same uh
formulation we saw during lecture one
but now we are discretizing time. So
time is no longer a continuous variable
is a discrete variable and each time
instant is denoted by TK
or stage
K the two terminologies are equivalent
time TK could be the discretization
could be time 0 0.1.2.3 2 0.3 or
equivalently we could say stage 0
corresponds to time time 0 stage k= 1
corresponds to time 0.1 stage k equal 2
corresponds to time 0.2 two and so on
and so forth. Now that we discretize
time, we have to discretise our update
equations. That is the mathematical
formalism that allow us to map the
current state and control into the next
state in the original optimal control
formulation that was given by a ordinary
differential equation. Now what we have
is a discrete time equation
which can either be derived from the
continuous time equation through
discretization or maybe it just uh the
most natural way to define the dynamics
for your system. But in case you you
derive it from the continuous time
equations, one very simple way to go
from a continuous time update equation
to discrete one is through eer
discretization. So say that your
dynamics are given by x dot= f of x u t
dot remember is derivative with respect
to time. Then the derivative can be
approximated as xt + delta t minus x of
t over delta t.
Which means that if you want to reason
in discrete time then you have the
discrete time update equation XT plus
delta t equal to
yeah is equal to x of t
plus delta
f of x u t. [snorts] And then you define
all of this
as your
new dynamics
equation. Now discretized.
So FG that will be the F here.
We have control constraints as usual. So
the use now also the controls are
discretized. You can take an action at
stage K, a stage K plus one and so on.
The controls at each stage K have to
belong to some set capital U that is
also a function of uh X. So your control
set can change depending on uh where you
are.
Control constraints could be you don't
want to accelerate uh uh you cannot
accelerate beyond a certain acceleration
level or you cannot impart thrust beyond
a certain thrust level and so on.
Then we had the cost function. So the
cost function structure is the same as
what we had for uh the optimal
continuous time optimal control problem
has an additive form. So there is a term
that sums up the stage wise contribution
to the cost. So this is the cost that
you pay at time K if you're in state X K
and you use control U K. Think about the
fuel that you're spending or maybe how
unhappy you are about being a state s
and hnxn is the terminal cost how
unhappy you are when at the end of your
optimization horizon. So after capital n
time steps you state x of n.
So this is also the discretized version
that we derive when you
when we discuss about direct methods.
So everything stays the same. The main
difference is that now we are
interesting in finding optimal closed
loop policies. That is we want to find
the the solution in the form of a
function pi.
Star means optimal in optimization in
general that maps
wherever whatever state you're in and
whatever time you're in into the optimal
thing to do with respect to this cost
function
before it would have been when we were
talking about open loop controls would
the object we were optimizing over was
simply the sequence of U0 start U1 start
and so on and so forth.
not a function of the state. Now we want
to find it as a function of the state.
It might sound as
simple terminology. This has a very deep
implications
as explained before
it should make sense. What do you think?
All right. So [snorts] now the question
is
how do we find an algorithm
to find such an optimal closed loop
policy.
And the key to crack the problem is to
recognize that this problem does have
structure. And the structure in this
problem can be used to derive a fairly
efficient algorithm referred to as
dynamic programming. And the structure
that this problem has is referred to as
the principle of optimality which is the
consequence of using
an additive cost as our cost function.
If instead of a summation you use
something else, the tangent of the this
the sum of the stuff that doesn't work
anymore. So here you see how our
formulation is a good compromise between
being relatively general but also having
enough structure for us to derive usable
uh actionable algorithms.
So what is the principle optimality? The
principle optimality is a fairly simple
concept in my experience. The first time
that you hear about it, you think it's
obvious. If you think more about it, you
get a bit confused, but then after a
while, it becomes obvious again.
So, let me state the principle
optimality. Principal optimality
essentially says that if you have a
multi-step
optimal uh control problem, so you're
optimizing operations over multiple
steps.
details of an optimal policy are optimal
for the truncated problem. I'll explain
better what I mean. Let me first show um
a simple statement of the principle
optimality and a proof of it. So let's
assume that we want to solve an optimal
control problem that is abstractly
represented
as finding uh
some path in some space.
So suppose that you have an initial
condition referred to as A and you have
a final condition referred to as E and
you want to go from A to E. And to do so
you have to enact uh a number of uh
decisions. You thrust in one direction
and after a while you thrust in another
direction. you keep going and then you
get to your final condition E.
So let's assume that uh the optimal path
stemming from the optimal selection of
controls first leads you to B
and then through a number of additional
decisions leads to E through this path.
So this piece here
is the realization
of many
additional
controls
control inputs.
Now let's call the cost of transitioning
from A to B along this path as a J A B
and let's call the cost of transitioning
from B to E along this specific pass
path as J B E.
So according to our formulation, what is
the total cost for going from A to E
along what I claim is an optimal path?
>> A to E.
>> That's right. Because we're assuming
that we have an additive cost. So the
optimal cost J uh from A to E is simply
the sum of J
A B plus J B and that stems from the
fact that we formulated the optimal
control problem with respect to a cost
function that is add additive.
So what the principle automaticity is
saying is that if
the red highlighted path A first we go
to B and then we go to E along this red
highlighted path. So if this path is
optimal to go from A to E then the tail
of it is optimal for the truncated
problem. So if I were to reformulate the
problem now starting from B.
So now you should say well I mean that
sounds obvious
but let's prove it. So what I'm saying
is that if A to B and then B to E along
the red highlighted path is the indeed
optimal path to go from A to E then the
tail of this path meaning the uh path
that starts at B and bring us to E is
optimal for the problem when started at
B.
And let's prove this statement by um
contradiction.
So proving by contradiction means that
uh uh we negate the claim and we'll see
that we'll come up with a contradiction
with our hypothesis which in turns
proves that the claim has to be true.
That is suppose by contradiction that
what I'm saying is not true. That is for
the problem whereby we start at B and we
want to get to E
in the most optimal way. There is indeed
another strategy whereby we first go to
some state let's call it C and then we
follow a path that goes to E.
If this total path is indeed the optimal
one for the problem that starts at B, it
means that uh um
J
B going to C first and going to E.
Let's call this cost J B C E is less
than JB.
JB E is the cost of the red highlighted
path. J B C E is the cost of going to E
first going through the state C
because of this different path.
Well, if that was true, it means that I
would have found a better path to go
from A to E. Simply the one that goes
from A to B first, then to C, and then
to E. Because of this, the cost of this
path would now be J
A B plus a J BCE,
which will be strict will be strictly
less less than J A B plus A J B
because of this.
Which means that I would have found
a better path to go from A to E.
contradicting the claim contradicting
the assumption that A be is the optimal
path to go from A to E. So we have
achieved a contradiction which proves
our claim that if you have an optimal
control sequence the tail of such a
sequence is optimal for the tranity
problem.
Does it make sense? more or less spend a
little time to think about it the even
though this you know um this principle
seems quite harmless actually has
profound implications. Yeah.
>> Is it just the tail of your sequence
it's not true for any subset of of paths
say you have a b
>> it has to be for the tail.
>> Just the tail.
>> The tail. Yes. And yeah let me say for
now it's just the tail. Yes.
Um
so let me reformulate now the principal
optimality in in the same formalism that
I discussed before to state the discrete
time optimal control problem. So what
the principal optimatic is saying is
that if u zero star u1 star u star n
minus one is an optimal controlled
sequence
which together with xar zero determines
the corresponding state sequence xar0 x1
star xar n and so on.
Consider then the sub problem whereby we
are at the state xar k at time k and we
wish to minimize the truncated problem
whereby we start at xar k and we only
look at the cost after time k
then the traned optimal sequence so the
sequence whereby we now start at uk star
is optimal for the sub problem which
means is which like a more nemonic way
to remember this condition is the tail
of optimal the tail of optimal sequence.
The tail optimal sequences are optimal
for the tail sub problems.
So you say who cares? We'll see in a
second why we do care about this. Yes,
>> this formulation a little bit like
triangle inequality or inequality
really similar ideas in different
packaging where they actually
>> I think it's even more basic idea that
follows from uh the additive assumption
that we make in the cast you see it here
the only reason why we could make um
this um claim is because we could assume
addictivity in the
by the way is in a weaker condition
because the only thing that we're saying
is that we need to have additivity no
matter which we space your optimization
could be over.
So that's why this property is so
general.
So the next question is what do we care
about this?
So let me give a little bit of intuition
about why we care about this. So suppose
that again we are in a setting whereby
we want to find an optimal path. So the
final destination is F. And suppose that
an oracle is giving you the solution to
go optimally from a point E to F with
cost Jar EF. It's giving you this
optimal solution to go from D to F with
cost Jar BF.
and it's giving you the optimal solution
to go from C to F with casters J star CF
and oracle the instructor that's giving
you this information and these optimal
paths may be the result of the
application of 324 control inputs. So
there is a lot of computation that went
into computing these paths
[clears throat]
and now it's a midterm and you have uh
three minutes to answer this question.
So I'm giving you now the problem of
going from a B to F
and from A B you can go to only three
states. You can go to C directly with
cost JBC. You can go to D directly with
cost JBD or you can go to E directly
with cost JBE.
And then I ask you and of course I give
you this cost and then I ask you to
compute the optimal path to go from B to
F.
So if you knew nothing about the
principle optimality, what you would
need to do is to consider each one of
these options and then resolve for all
possible control combinations for the
tail pass.
you wouldn't have a way to actually use
the information that I given to you. But
now you know about the principle of
optimality and the principle of
optimality is telling you that if the
arc BC is the initial segment of the
optimal path from B to F then C to F is
the terminal segment of this path. That
is there is no reason for you to
consider any farther combinations of
possible control inputs for the tail of
problems because you know that the tail
of an optimal um problem
the tail of um an optimal control
sequence is optimal for the tail
problem. So there is no additional
optimality you can gain but further
optimizing the truncated problem. So
what that means is that instead of brute
force solving the entire problem from
the beginning,
you can just do simple concatenation. So
you just look at three options.
concatenating the initial segment with
the optimal solution to the tail problem
one. Second possible initial segment
with the optimal solution to the second
tail problem and third segment with the
optional solution to the third problem.
So you only have to look at three
choices as opposed to recmp compute
everything from scratch.
So that's a part where things get a bit
more interesting and things may get
slightly confusing. But I hope that this
example clarifies it. So let's suppose
for example, yeah,
>> those three tail segments are all the
same costs. Yeah.
>> No, they don't need to be the same cost.
Actually, in general, they have
different cost. But what I'm saying is
that each one of them is optimal for the
particular sub problem where I start
from E, I start from either from D and
for or for C.
give an example when this wouldn't be
very obvious just because like looking
at the image um
I'm I struggle to understand like why if
we didn't know the principle of
optimality if we started with uh the
cost function from B to C why we would
choose them from D to F and not just
from C to F.
>> Uh uh could you repeat the last part?
I'm just a little confused why we would
decide if we were going from B to C is
wouldn't the obvious thing be to go from
C to F like why look at D to F for
example if you're already doing B to C
so first of all there might be multiple
paths to go from C to F or from D to F
or [snorts] from E to F and here I'm
just just showing the optimal one
if you go from B to C yes Sure, it's
obvious a little bit considering P
optimality that the right thing to do is
to go straight through the optimal path.
But what is not obvious since these each
of these costs are different and each of
these costs are different starting from
B which one of the three options you
should choose
that's a nonobvious part yes if you are
committed to go to C to C
then yes it's obvious that you would
need but again it's obvious because I
just explained the principle of
optimality otherwise that's why it's the
principle optimality is a bit sketches a
concept because it's obvious that
sometimes people really fail to fully
appreciate its death. So it's yes it's
obvious but you know there is some
cleverness into it. I'm going to give
you also another example to hopefully
make things even clearer. But anyway the
main point of this slide is to show how
with a principle optimality we can reuse
computation that has already been done
either by an oracle or as we will see by
us through a recursive algorithm.
so that you minimize the amount of
computation that you do overall.
So bottom line is that applying the
principle optimality as allows you to
compare the concatenations of immediate
decisions and optimal decisions in order
to compute a optimal control sequence
for an optimal problem that has been
extended by one step.
Now then the next question is uh who is
solving those state problems for you
in general you don't have an article.
So that's where the
somewhat uh uh unint non-intuitive idea
of dummy programming comes in. You solve
the problem backward in time even though
of course time moves forward in time. So
you deploy your policy going forward in
time. The problem is solved backward in
time. You start from the end simply
because at the end the optimal solution
it's obvious.
There is no solution. You are at the
end. So the there is nothing you should
do and the cost is also obvious. It's
just a terminal cost.
That means that you know the terminal,
you know the optimal solution at the
terminal stage. But now we have a
procedure to go one step at a time
backward by just concatenating immediate
costs
with the solution to the tail problems.
The first time you do it, you just have
uh the terminal cost and this the
boundary condition is given to you and
then you start applying it recursively
this idea and for the rest of the
lecture I'm going to give you a bit more
intuition about uh this procedure which
is uh extremely general but let me start
with one example where we're going to do
these backward recussions by by hand and
this example is more mechanical that
just to show the mechanics of it. But
then later on we're also going to
explore how much computational savings
this buys us. So now we have a shortest
path problem that is a bit more
concrete. We want to start from A and we
want to go to H.
And uh the transitions that are possible
are denoted by these arrows which means
that you have if you are at B you can
move right to state C with cast equal to
9.
Oh, for example, if you're at C, you can
move only right
actually know you can move right to F
with cost three or you can move upward
with cost five. So the question is
what is the best path to go from A to H?
If you knew nothing about dynamic
programming, what you would do is to
compute all possible combinations.
So you go down, you go right, you go up,
that's one possible sequence. You go
right, that's another branch of your
sequence. You consider all possible
combinations that are physible and then
you pick the one with minimum cost. Now
actually we're going to use the op the
principle of optimality to be a bit more
principle in how we do search
specifically we start from the back. So
what is the cost
for the
shortest path problem
whereby we start at uh h.
So that's a tail problem where we start
at h. So what is the cost?
We have h and we want to go to h zero.
Great. So we know actually the solution
to this tail problem. So now let's go
one step
backward.
For example here G.
So what is the cost of G? So the cost of
G
is equal to the immediate cost
two to go upward
and then I have the tail problem. It
starts at H.
I don't have to resolve for that
problem. I already have a solution. So
this would be the 2 + GH. But I have
already solved for H. H is equal to
zero. So the optimal cost is two.
So let's assume that now we are at f.
So what is the optimal cost to go from f
to h? Well, is the immediate cost
which is uh three
plus
the cost of the K problem which is also
referred to as cost to go which is J J
of G which is equal to. So this is equal
to five
and then we go one step backward. So now
we have a J
of E. So E is a kind of interesting case
because we have two options.
So
remember the more abstract figure that I
had before. I have two options. I can uh
either go right. I have an immediate
cost equal to 8 and then I transition
directly to H.
So the cost of this path will be 8 + j
of h.
But then I can also go down
in current cost two and transition into
state f.
But I don't have to recomputee what is
the optional thing to do from f. I
already have computed before. So this
will be 2 + j of f.
Is this correct? So A + GH 2 plus GF.
[snorts] So GH already computed. So this
is equal to zero. GF already computed.
This is equal to five. So now I just
pick the minimum between two. So this is
equal the first path is eight. Second
path is seven. So I pick the path that
goes to F and the cost will be uh seven.
Then I go one step backwards. So I have
J of D.
So this is equal to 3 + G.
G already computed. So this is equal to
10.
Then I have C. So J of C is equal to the
minimum
between 3 + JF
and
fly five plus JD.
No need to recmp compute JD.
I can re recycle the fact that I already
solved for the for the tail problems. J
D is equal to 10.
JF is equal to five.
So 3 + 5 is 8 15. So the optimal cost is
eight.
Um
yes. Then JB
is equal to
9 + JC.
[clears throat]
So this is called is equal to 17. And
finally I hit my initial condition
A. So I have two options. I can either
go right 8 + JD
or I can go down 5 + JB.
GD already computed is equal to 10.
JB already computed equal to 17.
10 + 8 wins. So optimal cost equal to
18.
And now
I can backtrack what the minimizer was
at uh every stage of the optimization.
So from A we selected
this one as a minimizer. So from A we
want to go to D.
From D we have only one options. We go
to E. And from E
is what the minimizer we go to F from F
to G and from G to H.
>> Yeah.
>> Like for instance, how do we know that
from H
and there is between step and
>> yeah great question. So in order to run
dynamic programming you have to put your
problem in the mathematical formalism
that I explained before. So here we will
need to define states and time steps in
terms of uh uh how many steps before we
uh hit the uh final condition and there
are ways to actually formulate the
shortest paths in such a way. So the k
the index will be the number of steps to
get to uh you know your destination h.
So in other words we want to
that's actually the tricky part of
dynamic programming. That's where
dynamic programming gets tricky.
Let me I'll get to you in a second.
Dynamic programming gets tricky in the
following way. Once your problem is
defined in the canonical way. So you
have discrete time uh equation for your
dynamics and then you have an additive
cost for your optimization problem.
Then at least conceptually the algorithm
is trivial.
You solve a recursive algorithm where
you start from a boundary condition
whereby you set the optimal solution to
the tail problem. It is the problem that
starts at the final condition as the
terminal cost and then you iterate one
step backward until you reach the
initial state x of zero.
at at each iteration
leveled by the time step K, you solve a
minimization problem whereby you're
trying to solve for a given state X of K
the optimal control the best compromise
between immediate cost and so-al cost to
go. to the cost of the truncated
problem.
And as you can tell, I mean, this is
very simple to implement conceptually,
but there are a few caveats. First of
all, there are a number of problems that
uh at first at the first look they seem
they seem to be completely
uh different from the way that I'm
stating the problem here. And that's
where the cleverness of the designer
goes. You map those problem into this
formalism. And even though I haven't
shown you but I think we have a homework
otherwise I will put a a reference on
canvas. There is a way to map the
shortest path problems exactly in this
formalism.
So that's the first caveat. So there is
some work and uh uh we'll see a couple
of examples whereby you take a problem
for example even DNA sequencing that the
first value seems has nothing to do with
dynamic programming you can put in this
formalism and once you have it in have
the problem formulating this formalism
you can just run the algorithm
so you say okay then it's more of a
modeling exercise no it's also an
algorithmic exercise because
even though ding programming
allows you to decrease substantially the
amount of computations with respect to
brute forcing the computation.
Keep in mind that you have to carry out
this optimization problem whereby you're
trying to find the optimal control at
time k that optimizes this class
function. You have to do that for all
time steps and for all possible states.
And even time is even though time has
been discretized technically the state
has to be discretized. So in principle
this could be a continuous quantity. So
you cannot even run these recussion
because you would have infinite many of
these recussions or even if you
discretize it you may have a very large
number of possible state combinations.
Let me clarify this a little bit. So say
that um
say that your state is one-dimensional
belongs to the interval 01 and you are
discretizing
discretise
with the 0.1 step
[clears throat]
and say that the time
is also
between 01 and you also discretize it
with 0.1 step. So how many dynamic
programming recussions meaning how many
of those optimization problems you have
to solve
per step you have 10 for each possible
value of the state but then you have a
10 time steps so you have 100 okay so
you have 10 * 10
now let's assume time stays the same but
let's assume that now we go into the
setting whereby x is two dimensional
So for example, position and velocity of
a double integator.
How many D programming recussions you
have to carry out
per each time step? How many possible
combination of states do you have?
That's right. So you have 100. So now
you have 10 which is the number of steps
time 100.
So now let's assume that uh is three
dimensional.
So now x is uh 0.1
cross 01 cross 01.
So basically you are optimizing over
three variables x y and z.
So now you have 10 time steps as before
but now you have 10 * 10 * 10.
So basically your dynamic regressions
scale
with 10 to the power of D where D is the
dimension of your state. So you have an
exponential scaling.
So even though dynamic programming and
you can show this more formally
uh dramatically decreased the amount of
computations that you had to carry out
still in general you have to carry out a
lot of computations
particular in high dimensional state
spaces
anyway so assuming that you can do that
so two main challenges a modeling one
whatever problem you are it's possible
that you can map it into not all
problems of course can be mapped into
this formalism. But there are some
problems that a face value may not look
like that are amenable to this
formulation, but they are. So there is a
little bit of cleverness that goes into
that. And then there is of course work
that goes into making sure that you can
run dynamic programming cultures at
scale. So this is the call the topic of
so-cal approximate dynamic recussion
that will also lead into the second part
of this class referred to as learning
based control.
Now assuming that you can solve this
problem
then you can construct an optimal policy
by essentially bookkeeping for all
possible states associating the optimal
control that you have picked and so you
are incrementally building the optimal
control policy path.
So there is a lot here. This is a very
fundamental result in controls is the
basis of u uh discrete time closed loop
optimal control continuous time closed
loop optimal control learning based
control and policy learning. So
everything exciting that you hear these
days about uh policy learning vision
language action models all that stuff is
rooted in this equation.
of course with many generalizations.
Now [snorts] if you think about this
equation
we derive it somewhat formally
by basically stating the problem stating
the principle optimality and then just
uh applying it in order to derive this
recussion.
But if you think about it it's quite
natural. So what is it saying
is that uh assuming that you at a given
state
the optimal thing to do right now is
what minimizes the impact of the of that
action on your immediate cost
plus the implication what you do today
in terms of what will happen tomorrow
starting from tomorrow.
If you think about this is very natural.
Why are you here today
and not on a beach?
Because you are trading off your
immediate gains with future gains. Of
course, going to the beach to, you know,
um, uh, have a nice swim in the ocean
improves your cost right now, but has
implications about your future
education,
right? So, your cost to go is affected.
So, actually you are here because you
are sacrificing your immediate wealth in
order to optimize your future wealth.
So, that's what dynamic programming is
doing. is really compromising the
immediate gains with the implication of
what you do today starting from tomorrow
and is do so in a mathematical the right
way that is uh principle yeah
[clears throat]
>> confused about how we end up reaching
our initial condition cuz like if you
have a final condition that's really far
away from your initial condition I don't
understand how like especially in the
beginning it doesn't seem like there's
any way the optimal solution would
in any way towards it.
>> Yeah, that's why you solve backward. So
you start backward and then ah I see
what you're saying. So uh when you have
x0
you might actually you are solving
actually the problem for all possible
initial conditions and then you give me
the uh initial condition you're
interested in and for that one
specifically we find an optimal control
policy. But in a way you're right. So
the dynamic programming problem to solve
the solution to find the solution to the
problem that you really care about the
one with a specific initial condition
x0= 1 comma 3 is actually solving all
the tails of problems and all the full
problems for all possible initial
conditions.
Or maybe you at the last iteration you
can just be smart and only carry out
this recussion for jx0. But in general
for all the intermediate steps you have
to solve the tail problems from all
possible states you that are reachable
because you don't know from the initial
condition you're interested in which
intermediate states you'll be visiting.
So in in that way is a bit wasteful but
the good news though is that at least uh
you still save quite a bit in
computation and then if problem data
changes or initial condition changes you
have solved the problem for all possible
conditions.
It seems that in the previous example we
were sort of like processing nodes in a
specific order.
>> Yeah, that's basically the equation. So
what I have not shown um and I'll
provide the reference is it's a bit
convoluted but not too convoluted. You
can what they did was a bit adhawk but
you can actually map a shortest path
problem computation exactly in this
format
and I'll post that on
>> so like in general do you also need to
like some sort of ordering process
>> state yeah because you need to put it in
that formalism
and the ordering there is the number of
hops we are optimizing over. So we first
optimize over paths that reach the um
final destination in one hop. Then we
optimize over pass that reach the final
destination in two hops. We then
optimize etc etc.
So in the case the number of hops is the
number of stages. Okay.
So a few comments. So I already talked
about the discretization aspect. So
that's basically how we formulated the
problem. We went from differential
equations to difference equations. We
talked about how dynamic programming
recussion has to be carried out for each
possible value of the state. If the
state is continuous, then we have to
quantize it. Dynamic programming
actually is trying to find a global
minimum for each dynamic programming
recursion. So it's going to give you the
globally optimal solution.
If there are constraints that is
typically constraints make the
optimization problem much harder as you
saw with direct methods and
like range optimization but in this case
constraints actually make the problem
simpler because reduce the number of
actions roughly speaking you have to
optimize over. So you have less uh
things to consider. It gives you a
solution in closed loop form but it is
affected by the car dimensionality. What
the car dimensionality refers to is the
exponential scaling of the number of
computations needed with respect to the
dimension of the state space.
I have a question on the principal
optimality where you said that it's only
the tail um sub sub path that is like
the shortest path. Um wouldn't isn't it
true that if that's the global minimum
that any like sub path with like
regardless of whether it's the like the
tail end path is also the shortest path
here.
>> Yes. I mean that's a principal
optimality.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Absolutely. Every tail path
is going to be optimal. Yes. [snorts] Um
so we started from the optimal problem
formulation. We derived that the most
essential structure that this problem
has refers to as a principle optimality.
We argue how leveraging this structure
we can find an optional algorithm to
solve these problems. This algorithm has
a quirk. The quirk is that it involves
optim uh doing computation backward in
time.
And there is a nice quote from a
philosopher
that is loosely
I mean actually this philosopher lived
before Bman that introduced the nimatic
principle but it's kind of nice uh
philosophical
association let's put it this way that
uh life
has to
the leave forward.
That's obvious because time goes forward
in time, but
can only
be
understood
backward.
I don't know how much you resonate, but
sometimes, you know, you you look at
where you are and you see, shoot, I
didn't realize that that decision that I
made four years ago wouldn't let me
here. So, that's how I understand things
backwards.
I don't know. It reminds me of this
quote. It's up to you if you resonate or
not.
uh one thing
for your exam
very likely that I will ask you to
compute one step of a dynamic program
recussion to make sure that you
understand what to do it's going to be
relatively simple it will take five
minutes what I'm saying is make sure
that you internalize
uh what one step of a progression
algorithm entails
>> what is it about this dynamic
programming approach that makes it close
to as opposed to what we were learning
last week.
>> Yes, that now we are solving uh uh
problems for all possible tail problems
from all possible states we could reach.
That's a completely different mindset
for what we were doing uh before. By
doing so you are basically computing an
optimal control for each possible state
you are in which is really definition of
a closed loop optimal control. So this
different view uh different with respect
to what we had before that allows us to
compute uh closed loop control policies.
So a significant shift in uh mindset.
All right. So let's wrap up this lecture
with by solving
a relatively simple but extremely
foundational optimal control problem
which is referred to as a LQR linear
quadratic regulator.
So the LQR problem is a specific class
of discrete time optimal control problem
is fine as follows. Our dynamics are
linear. So sk + 1 is equal to a x k + b
u k x the state use the control a is a
given matrix matrix of numbers b is also
a given matrix does not depend on the
state does not depend on control
um this referred to as the state matrix.
This is the input matrix. The cost is
additive and is quadratic. So we have a
terminal cost which is a quadratic form
in terms of the terminal state x of n
and then the stage wise cost is
quadratic too is a quadratic in terms of
the state and is a quadratic in terms of
the control.
U square basically models how unhappy
you are about uh using control U. X
square is basically telling us how
unhappy you are you are about being a
state X since you are squaring the state
you can see how the here the object what
objective essentially modeling is that
you want to go to the origin where the
state x is equal to zero so that you
don't pay any cost and you want to do so
with a control u that minimizes the sum
of the u squares
So you want to basically minimize
energy.
And of course there is a little bit of a
conflict here. Maybe with a larger U you
might get to the origin quicker but then
you have a bigger control effort. But
then if you make smaller steps you'll
eventually get to the origin and you pay
less control but you are very unhappy
for a lot of steps because you are far
from the origin for a lot of steps. So
basically it's time to find this
balance. This problem is referred to as
a regulator because essentially is
modeling the problem of getting to the
origin with minimum cost.
Now for this quadratic cost to make
sense we are requiring that the h Q q
and r of positive semidefinite so that
these are actually uh non- negative
terms as we will see later we are also
strengthening the condition for r to be
positive definite.
So this is the control penalty. This is
the state penalty and this is the
terminal state penalty matrix.
Does the problem make sense?
I stated that doesn't seem to be a
particularly
um useful problem. I mean you want we
want to get to the origin but in general
who cares about getting to the origin.
As we will see actually this problem
formulation is uh extremely useful and
popular. It can readily be used in the
context of trajectory tracking problems
as we will see on uh Wednesday and also
as a useful algorithm to even solve the
linear optimization problems through
successive linearizations.
So even in the most complicated say end
to end models for autonomous driving
chances are that your track we put
vision language action models word
models foundation models what have you
chances are that your trajectory
tracking algorithm is somewhat LQR
derived so there's an important concept
[clears throat] so we're looking at this
problem for two reasons one because it's
an important class of problems
especially as we will discuss on the
Wednesday but two is also one example
for me to uh showcase dynamic
programming. Why? We are exactly in the
setting of dynamic programming. We have
discrete time equation and uh uh we have
a cost that is additive which means we
can solve the problem with dynamic
programming. How does it work? Well,
there is no much cleverness that goes
into the solution. You start with the
boundary condition basically the cost at
the end. So if you're in a state x of n
the cost is simply 12 xn transpose h x
of n
and also let me denote as a definition
this cost with one else xn transpose pn
xn so basically I'm referring to h as pn
we this will become clear later for now
just remember
of course we want to solve the problem
from the perspective of x0 zero. But to
do so, we had to run dynamic
programming. So we start by going one
step backward. So now we say for all
possible states uh that are reachable at
time n minus one. I have no clue which
state the optimal state trajectory will
go through. So I have to consider all
possible ones that are reachable from
x0. So for each one of them,
let's call each one of them xnus one.
So if this is one dimensional and
between 0 and one discretizing with the
step 0 one I would do it for state xn= 0
xn is equal 0.1 0.2 0.3 all the way to
10. Well, for each one of them, I try to
find a control at time n minus one
that minimizes the
immediate cost which is uh the quadratic
in x n minus one and the quadratic in u
minus one and the optimal cost to go. So
jar n x of n which in this case is
simply xn h xn
the cost of the problem for the state I
transition into which will be the
problem uh at the next stage.
Okay. So,
but x of n is simply given by
a n -1 x n - one + b n -1 u n - one.
So, I plug
u this relationship in here.
And as you can see
now this optimization problem is just um
an optimization problem with respect to
the variable u n minus one. x n minus
one is fixed because for each dynamic
programming recussion you're doing it
for the specific value of xn minus one.
QR a b is all and h is all problem data
given to you. The only quantity that is
a variable here is u nus one. But this
is a problem is very simple to solve.
It's just a quadratic in u n minus one.
We have some a quadratic term coming
from here and here. So what is this
quantity? So we have
we have a n -1 x n -1 + b n -1 u n -1
transpose h a x n x n -1 n -1 + b n -1 u
n -1.
So this is equal to
well we have the quadratic in u n minus
one. So we have a u n minus one
um transpose
b n -1 transpose h b -1 u n - one. So
that's the quadratic in u n - one. Then
we have the quadratic in x n - one. So
this plus plus x n -1 transpose
a n - one transpose h a n -1 xn - one
and then we have the cross terms. So we
have a plus u n -1 transpose b n -1
transpose
h a x n - one plus the other term plus x
n -1 transpose
a n -1 transpose
um h
b -1 u n minus one. So you have a
quadratic in u linear in u and then
non-dependency in u. So now to find the
minimum you take the derivative with
respect to u minus one.
So
we also have the the quadratic here in u
and then we have no dependency u here.
So when you take the derative with
respect to u this goes away. This is a
quadratic. So the derivative with
respect to u is simply r u
remember there is a 1/2 that's
multiplying all of that
and then I leave this as an exercise for
you but then you take a derivative you
keep take dative of all this stuff here
so here you're left with term that is
linear into u brpose h bu
brranspose h bu and and uh you take the
derivatives with respect to determin
linear u this guy and this guy and then
you sum them up remember that you have a
1/2 in front of all the stuff and what
you get is transport h a xn
I leave it to you the detailed
computation super easy and then that's a
necessary condition for optimality you
get to the second order derivative to
find the sufficient one so taking
another round of derivatives with
respect to u the derivative of this term
with respect to u is R that the derative
of all this term with respect to U is
branspose H B
and this stuff is positive definite
because we assume that R is positive
definite.
So
what is the um
so what is the uh optimal u well is the
one that satisfy the necessity condition
so you solve for the first equation in
terms of u so you grouped everything in
terms of u and then you take an inverse
so not going to through all the steps
because it's really simple algebra the
inverse exists because r is positive
definite so This entire object is
positive definite which means the
determinant isn't zero. You can take the
the inverse.
Okay. So we have found the optimal
solution
and look how that's the interesting part
here that this optimal solution is going
to be given by an ugly multiplication of
matses but this is system data stuff
that is given to you times the state. So
actually the optimal control is a linear
feedback on the state. It's just a sum
matrix f times x.
Great makes a lot of sense. And of
course there are deeper relationship
with the linear controls. So fn minus
one is defined as the multiplication of
all these matrices.
Okay. [snorts]
But then what is the cost for the tail
problems? So we plug back in the optimal
control input as we computed into the
cost. So now we plug
u = fx
back into here. So this will be xrpose n
-1 f -1 transpose r fn -1 x - one. So
you plug all that in
and again I'm not going to through go
through the steps if you don't trust me
you can go through them but basically
what I get is a quadratic form in terms
of the state xnus one.
Just do it as an exercise. You pick u=
fx as the optimal solution. go back into
the cost function with that uh form of u
and what you get that the cost is a
quadratic in x.
So then you start seeing some pattern.
We started with a quadratic cost xnus
one h x n minus one. Oh actually I said
no let's for terminology let's call that
hpn. So we started with the con was
quadratic xn minus one transpose pn xn
minus one. I found that for going one
step backward the optimal control is
linear feedback on the state and the
optimal cost for the tail problems is a
quadratic in the state.
So what happens if you go one step
backward? You started with a quadratic
optimal cost to go and you ended up with
an optim a quadratic optimum cost for
the tail. So if you go one step
backward,
what do you think is going to happen to
the cost? It's going to be quadratic
cubic. We don't know
mathematically the problem has exactly
the same structure. So you're going to
be faced with exactly the same problem
you are formulating just that now
instead of having n minus one the
subscript you have n minus2
which essentially means we found
uh a very nice pattern where we can
solve this problem by recussions but
instead of solving an optimal problem an
optimization problem at each step you
just solve a recursive equation on the
matrices fk and pk. So you start from a
boundary condition setting PN equal H.
Then you set the gain for the optimal
control F of K equal to all the stuff.
This is stuff that depends on problem
data of stuff that has already been
computed at the previous step.
given the gain. Then you compute the
cost from the perspective of time K
by updating PK according to this
relatively ugly but simple to implement
equation whereby you're just multiplying
the problem data and stuff that has been
already computed and then you go one
step backward. Does it make sense? So
it's just one lucky case whereby the
dynamic programming recussion boils down
to recussion on some matrices.
These equations actually are very
important in uh control and are referred
to as Ricati equation. Ricati was a
mathemat Italian mathematician.
So as you know
I'm originally from Italy. So I do care
that you spell ricati correctly. So
ricati
is two C's here
and one C. For whatever reason, I don't
know why in the United States sometimes,
often times this is referred to as
either ricati
or ricati.
By the way, ricati in Italian means
blackmailing. So not this one, not this
one, this one. Okay, to see one here.
Great.
So bottom line here. So we discussed the
foundations of uh closed loop optimal
control. We discussed how by using
fundamental structure in our problem
formulation referred to as the principle
optimality we can derive an actionable
algorithm referred to as dynamic
programming. The programming is purely
procedural means that once you're given
the problem formulination you just write
down in Python these days maybe use code
to v your recussion that's the easy part
the hard part is on the modeling side
making sure that your problem is
efficiently formulated in the same
formalism of the optimal control
formulation I'll share uh a pager that
shows you how to do that for the
shortest part problem since there were a
couple of questions today and of
Doing dynamic programming at scale
requires a number of approximations that
we will discuss later on in this class.
That's the hard part of dynamic
programming. [snorts] We look at a
special case of dynamic programming
which is dynamic programming applied to
LQR. LQR is a problem of its own
interest as we will see particular
Wednesday has a number of very useful
applications in uh robotics and controls
tracking nonlinear optimal control and
we'll see and the beauty of LQR is that
uh the diamond programming recussions
simplify into recussions about just two
quantities. the gain matrix for the
optimal controller which is provably in
the linear feedback form and another
matrix P that tells you the cost for
each tail of problem and of course LQR
was also a way for me to give an example
about uh carrying out the program
make sense so what we're going to do
next is then some Wednesday is to see
how a QR can be applied to a number of
additional problems that uh are very
very useful for doing robotics. All
right, see you on Wednesday.